A
COUPLE OF DAYS.
WE'VE GOT TO GET TO GIANNIS,
LIVE AT THE PODIUM ADDRESSING
THE MEDIA.
HE HAD EIGHT ASSISTS AND THREE
STEALS.
>> CAN YOU SEND ME THROUGH THE
BLOCK?
GIANNIS: JUST HUSTLE PLAY.
GOING DOWN THE STRETCH, JUST
DOING WHATEVER IT TAKES TO WIN
THE GAME, JUST PUT YOURSELF IN
THE POSITION THAT CAN BE THE
GAME.
I SAW THE PLAY COMING.
I AM JUST GOING TO JUMP
VERTICALLY TOWARDS THE RIM.
HOPEFULLY I CAN BE THERE IN
TIME.
I WAS THERE IN TIME AND WAS ABLE
TO GET A GOOD BLOCK AND GO DOWN
AND GET TWO POINTS.
IT WAS A GREAT HUSTLE PLAY.
>> IT FELT LIKE A STRANGE ANGLE,
LIKE IT WAS ONE OF THOSE SPOTS
WHERE THE TOSS CAME OUT OF
NOWHERE.
DID IT SURPRISE YOU AT ALL?
GIANNIS: IT DID NOT SURPRISE ME.
I SAW IT COMING.
ONCE I SAW HIM PUT IN HIS ONE
HAND, HE WAS TOO FAR FROM A
LAYUP, SO I KNEW HE WAS TRYING
TO LOB ME.
I HAD COMMITTED SO MUCH.
I FELT HIM ROLLING IN BEHIND ME.
I KNEW THE ONLY CHANCE TO GET A
STOP WAS TO JUST JUMP TOWARDS
THE RIM AND TRY TO COVER THAT
ANGLE FOR HIM TO SCORE.
>> HE THOUGHT AS HE WAS
GOING TO JUMP UP, HE WAS GOING
TO DUNK IT?
>> I WAS LATE.
IF I WERE ON THE OPPOSITE SIDE,
IT IS A DUNK.
BUT AS I SAID, I DID NOT JUMP TO
BLOCK THE BALL, I JUMPED TOWARDS
THE RIM.
I FELT LIKE THAT'S WHAT KIND OF
HELPED ME, PUT ME IT IN A
POSITION TO GET THE BLOCK.
THE RIM WAS RIGHT HERE SO I
JUMPED RIGHT HERE SO HE COULD
SHOOT THE BALL -- IF HE SHOT THE
BALL THROUGH THE BACKBOARD, IT
WOULD PROBABLY BE GOALTENDING,